MR: Sucedió después de hablar con Bina y nuestros 4 hermosos hijos,
y les conté a cada uno de ellos
que sentía que mi alma siempre fue la de una mujer
pero tenía miedo de que la gente se riera de mí
así que siempre la mantuve escondida
y solo mostré mi lado masculino.
Y cada uno de ellos tenía una opinión diferente sobre esto.
Bina dijo: "Me encanta tu alma,
y si te ves como Martin o Martine,
no me importa, me encanta tu alma".
Mi hijo dijo: "Si te conviertes en una mujer, ¿seguirás siendo mi padre?"
Y le dije: "Claro, siempre seré tu padre",
y sigo siendo su padre hasta hoy.
Mi hija pequeña hizo algo absolutamente brillante para sus 5 años.
Le dijo a la gente: "Yo amo a mi papá y ella me ama".
Así que no tenía ningún problema con la mezcla de géneros.
CA: Y un par de años más tarde publicaste este libro:
"El apartheid del sexo".
¿Cuál fue la tesis de este libro?
MR: La tesis de este libro es que hay 7000 millones de personas en el mundo,
por lo cual, 7000 millones de maneras únicas de expresar el género.
Y mientras que las personas pueden tener los genitales de un hombre o una mujer,
los genitales no determinan tu género
ni incluso tu identidad sexual.
Es solo una cuestión de anatomía
y tractos reproductivos,
y la gente puede elegir cualquier género que quiera
si no se ven obligados por la sociedad
a encajar en las categorías de masculino y femenino
igual que la gente de Sudáfrica fue separada por blancos y negros.
La antropología nos dice que la raza es ficción,
a pesar de que el racismo es muy, muy real.
Y ahora sabemos por los estudios culturales
que la separación por géneros es una ficción construida.
El género es en realidad un contínuo
y contiene toda una gama del hombre a la mujer.
CA: Tú mismo no siempre te sientes 100 % una mujer.
MR: Correcto. Yo diría que en cierto modo
puedo cambiarme de género tan a menudo como cambio de peinado.
CA: (Risas) Bueno, esta es tu preciosa hija, Génesis.
Y creo que a esa edad sucedió algo terrible.
MR: Sí, se dio cuenta de que no podía subir sola por las escaleras de casa
a su habitación,
y después de meses de consultas médicas,
fue diagnosticada con una enfermedad rara, casi mortal,
llamada hipertensión arterial pulmonar.
CA: ¿Cómo reaccionaste?
MR: En primer lugar fuimos a los mejores médicos que pudimos.
Terminamos en el Centro Médico Infantil de Washington, DC.
El jefe de cardiología pediátrica
nos dijo que recomendaba el trasplante de pulmón
pero que no nos hiciéramos muchas ilusiones,
porque existen muy pocos pulmones disponibles,
especialmente para los niños.
Dijo que todas las personas con esta enfermedad murieron,
y si alguno ha visto la película "El aceite de Lorenzo"
hay una escena en la que el protagonista
se cae por la escalera llorando y lamentando la suerte de su hijo,
y eso es exactamente cómo nos sentimos con Génesis.
CA: Pero no aceptaste estas limitaciones.
Has buscado otro tratamiento
para encontrar alguna cura posible.
MR: Sí, estuvo en cuidados intensivos
durante semanas cada vez,
y con Bina nos turnamos en el hospital
para que uno pudiera quedarse con el resto de los chicos,
y cuando estaba en el hospital y ella estaba durmiendo,
fui a la biblioteca del hospital.
Leí todos los artículos que pude encontrar sobre la hipertensión pulmonar.
Nunca estudié biología, ni siquiera en la universidad,
así que tuve que aprender desde el principio,
hasta llegar a textos de nivel universitario,
libros de especialidad médica, artículos de revistas y, finalmente,
sabía lo suficiente para creer que es posible encontrar una cura.
Así que creé una fundación sin ánimo de lucro.
Pedí subvenciones y también pedí a la gente que enviara donaciones
y nosotros pagaríamos la investigación médica.
Me convertí en un experto en el tema, pero los médicos me dijeron: "Martine,
realmente apreciamos tu financiamiento
pero no podremos encontrar una cura a tiempo
para salvar a tu hija.
Sin embargo, hay un medicamento
desarrollada por la Burroughs Wellcome Company
que podría detener el avance de la enfermedad,
pero Burroughs Wellcome acaba de ser comprada por Glaxo Wellcome.
Que decidieron no invertir
en ningún medicamento para las enfermedades raras
y tal vez podría usar tu conocimiento en las comunicaciones por satélite
para desarrollar esta cura para la hipertensión pulmonar.
CA: Entonces, ¿cómo conseguiste acceso a este medicamento?
MR: Fui a Glaxo Wellcome
y después de que me rechazaran 3 veces y me cerraran la puerta en la cara
diciéndome que no acordarán la licencia del medicamento
a un experto en comunicaciones por satélite
y de hecho a nadie de mi entorno en absoluto,
ya que pensaban que no tenía la experiencia necesaria,
pude persuadir a un pequeño equipo de personas que trabajará conmigo
y ganar credibilidad.
Pude superar su resistencia,
y el hecho de que no creían en la eficacia del fármaco,
pero me dijeron que estaba perdiendo el tiempo
y que lo sienten por mi hija.
Pero en última instancia, por USD 25 000
y un 10 % de los beneficios futuros
aceptaron cederme los derechos.
CA: Llegaste a comercializarlo de una manera realmente brillante,
Básicamente haciendo lo que hacía falta para que esto funcione.
MR: Oh, sí, Chris, pero al final no obtuve mi medicamento...
después de firmar el cheque de USD 25 000
dije: "Bueno, ¿dónde está el medicamento para Génesis?"
me dijeron "Martine, no hay medicina para Génesis.
Esto es solo algo que probamos en ratas".
Y me dieron una pequeña bolsa de plástico
que tenía una pequeña cantidad de polvo.
Me dijeron: "No se lo des a nadie",
y me dieron un pedazo de papel que decía que era la patente,
con el cual tuvimos que averiguar una manera de producir este medicamento.
100 químicos de las mejores universidades norteamericanas
juraron que la patente nunca podría convertirse en medicamento.
Y si se convierte en medicamento, nunca podría ser comercializada
porque se mantenía estable en media solo 45 minutos.
CA: Y sin embargo, un año o dos más tarde, tenías un fármaco
que funcionó para Génesis.
MR: Chris, lo sorprendente es que este polvo inútil
que tenía el brillo de una promesa de esperanza para Génesis
no solo la mantiene a ella y a otras personas con vida hoy,
sino que produce casi USD 1500 millones al año en ingresos.
(Aplausos)
CA: Allí está.
Eres una empresa pública, ¿no?
E hiciste una fortuna.
Y cuánto tuviste que pagarles a Glaxo además de los 25 000?
MR: Sí, bueno, todos los años les pagamos
un 10 % de los USD 1500 millones,
unos USD 150 millones, el año pasado USD 100 millones.
Es la mejor inversión con la que cuentan. (Risas)
CA: Y la mejor noticia de todas, supongo,
es esta.
MR: Sí. Génesis es una joven absolutamente brillante.
Está viva, sana y tiene 30 años.
Aquí estoy con Bina y Génesis.
Lo más sorprendente de Génesis
es que ella puede hacer lo que quiere con su vida,
y créanme, si hubieran crecido toda sus vidas rodeados de gente
que les hubiera dicho en la cara que tienen una enfermedad mortal,
probablemente se fueran corriendo a Tahití para no volver a ver a nadie conocido.
Pero en lugar de eso optó por trabajar en United Therapeutics.
Dice que quiere ayudar a los demás
con enfermedades huérfanas a recibir medicamentos.
Y hoy, ella es nuestra líder de proyecto
para todas las actividades de teleasistencia,
donde coordina digitalmente toda la empresa y trabajan juntos
para encontrar la cura para la hipertensión pulmonar.
CA: Pero no todos los que tienen esta enfermedad han sido tan afortunados.
Todavía hay muchas personas que mueren, y te ocupas de eso también. ¿Cómo?
MR: Exactamente, Chris. Hay unas 3000 personas
al año en Estados Unidos solamente,
quizás 10 veces más en todo el mundo,
que siguen muriendo de esta enfermedad
porque la medicina avanza lentamente
y para ellos el tiempo cuenta.
El único tratamiento para la hipertensión pulmonar, la fibrosis pulmonar,
la fibrosis quística, el enfisema,
EPOC, de cual sufría Leonard Nimoy,
es el trasplante de pulmón,
pero por desgracia, no hay suficientes pulmones disponibles
para las 2000 personas en EE.UU. cada año
o el casi un medio millón de personas en el mundo
que mueren de insuficiencia pulmonar.
CA: Entonces, ¿cómo se puede evitar esto?
MR: Yo barajo la posibilidad
de que al igual que mantenemos
coches, aviones y edificios para siempre
suministrando un número ilimitado
de piezas de construcción y piezas de recambio,
por qué no crear un suministro ilimitado de órganos trasplantables
para ayudar a las personas a vivir mucho más,
especialmente a las personas con enfermedad pulmonar.
Así que nos hemos asociado
con el decodificador del genoma humano, Craig Venter,
y la compañía que fundó
junto con Peter Diamandis, el fundador del Premio X,
para modificar genéticamente
el genoma porcino
con el fin de que sus órganos no sean rechazados por el cuerpo humano
y así crear un suministro ilimitado
de órganos trasplantables.
Lo hacemos a través de nuestra empresa, United Therapeutics.
CA: Entonces ¿realmente crees que dentro de digamos una década,
este déficit de pulmones trasplantables
se resolverá así?
MR: Por supuesto, Chris.
Lo estoy en la misma medida que lo estaba del éxito que hemos tenido
con Sirius XM, la radiodifusión en directo por la televisión.
En realidad no es tan difícil.
Es simple ingeniería entre genes.
Somos muy afortunados de haber nacido en un momento histórico
cuando la secuenciación del genoma
es una actividad rutinaria,
y el brillante equipo de Synthetic Genomics
puede adentrarse en el genoma del cerdo,
y encontrar exactamente los genes que dan problemas y arreglarlos.
CA: Pero no solo los cuerpos... eso es increíble.
(Aplausos)
Lo que te interesa ahora que dure ilimitadamente
no es solo el cuerpo sino también la mente.
Y creo que este gráfico significa mucho para ti.
¿Qué significa esto?
MR: Este gráfico hecho por Ray Kurzweil muestra
que el ritmo de desarrollo del procesamiento computarizado
del hardware, firmware y software,
ha ido avanzando en una curva que dentro de una década,
en 2020, como vimos en otras charlas hoy,
existirá una tecnología de la información
que procesará la información y el mundo alrededor de nosotros
al mismo ritmo que una mente humana.
CA: ¿Y te preparas para este mundo
convencido de que pronto podremos
tomar el contenido de nuestro cerebro
y de alguna manera preservarlo para siempre?
¿Cómo describirías esto?
MR: Bueno, Chris, estamos trabajando en la simulación de una situación
donde la gente puede crear un archivo de la mente,
como una colección de su comportamiento, personalidad,
recuerdos, sentimientos,
creencias, actitudes y valores,
todo lo que vemos hoy en Google, en Amazon, en Facebook,
y esta información almacenada
estará disponible en las próximas dos décadas,
en un software capaz de reproducir la conciencia,
de revivir la conciencia de los archivos.
CA: No estás bromeando con eso.
En serio. ¿Qué es esto?
MR: Es una versión robótica de mi amada esposa, Bina.
Y la llamamos Bina 48.
Fue programada por Hanson Robotics de Texas.
Hay un artículo en la revista National Geographic
con uno de sus cuidadores,
y también está en Internet,
con cientos de horas de los gestos de Bina y su personalidad.
Es como un niño de 2 años,
pero dice cosas que nos deja asombrados
algo que ha sido quizás mejor expresado
por la periodista del New York Times, Amy Harmon, ganadora del Premio Pulitzer
que dice que sus respuestas son a menudo frustrantes,
pero otras veces tan convincentes
como los de cualquier persona real que ha entrevistado.
CA: ¿Y esperas que esta versión
de Bina, u otra, vivan para siempre?
MR: Sí. No solo de Bina, sino de todo el mundo.
No nos cuesta nada añadir nuestros archivos mentales
en Facebook, Instagram, lo que quieran.
Los medios sociales son en mi opinión
los inventos más extraordinarias de nuestros tiempos,
y las aplicaciones disponibles nos permiten
cada vez sacar a Siri de Siri,
y desarrollar la conciencia de los sistemas operativos,
de todos en el mundo, miles de millones de personas,
que así podrán desarrollar clones mentales de sí mismos
que tendrán su propia vida en la web.
CA: Esta idea Martine
en cualquier conversación normal, parecería una idea absolutamente loca,
pero en el contexto de tu vida, de lo que has hecho hasta ahora
y algunas de las cosas que hemos oído esta semana,
la realidad intrínseca de la creación de un producto que contenga la mente
es algo por lo cual apuestas.
MR: Bueno, pero eso no me pertenece.
En todo caso, quizá comunico las actividades
que llevan a cabo las mayores empresas
en China, Japón, India, EE.UU., Europa.
Hay decenas de millones de personas trabajando y escribiendo código
que expresa cada vez más aspectos de nuestra conciencia humana,
y no hace falta ser un genio para ver a dónde lleva esto
que finalmente creará la conciencia humana,
y es algo que tenemos que valorar.
Hay tantas cosas que hacer en esta vida,
y si pudiéramos tener un clon de nosotros mismos
para ayudarnos a procesar libros, hacer las compras,
ser nuestros mejores amigos,
creo que nuestras versiones digitales
en última instancia, serán nuestros mejores amigos,
y para mí personalmente y para Bina personalmente,
nos amamos como locos.
Cada día nos decimos
que nos amamos más que hace 30 años.
Así que para nosotros la perspectiva de la clonación de la mente
y de los cuerpos regenerados
significa Chris que nuestra historia de amor puede durar para siempre.
Y no nos aburriremos juntos, esto no pasará.
CA: ¿Bina está aquí? MR: Sí.
CA: ¿Puede alguien traerme un micrófono de mano?
Bina, ¿podríamos invitarte al escenario? Solo quiero hacerte una pregunta.
Además, queremos verte.
(Aplausos)
Gracias, gracias.
Ven aquí con Martine.
Quiero decir, mira, cuando te casaste,
si alguien te hubiera dicho que en poco tiempo
el hombre con el cual te ibas a casar se convertiría en una mujer,
y unos pocos años después de eso, tú te convertirías en un robot...
(Risas)
¿qué hubieras dicho?
Bina Rothblatt: Eso ha sido un viaje emocionante,
y nunca lo hubiera pensado en aquel momento,
pero empezamos a ponernos metas y objetivos
y querer lograr cosas,
así que antes de darse uno cuenta, ya está transitando este camino
y todavía no hemos parando, es genial.
CA: Martine me dijo algo realmente hermoso,
antes de esto, por Skype,
que quería vivir durante cientos de años
como un archivo de la mente,
pero contigo.
BR: Es así, queremos hacerlo juntos.
Creemos en la criología y queremos despertar juntos.
CA: Desde mi punto de vista,
sus vidas son unas de las más sorprendentes que he oído,
y su historia de amor es una de las más asombrosas que he escuchado.
Ha sido un placer tenerte aquí en TED.
Muchas gracias.
MR: Gracias.
(Aplausos)